ma'am come on there has to be a release
where is the release its wrap it up okay
come on come on come on Oh God chase SI
anna BL all you crazy yeah hella high
I'll find who did this and I'll get Sean
back I promised her
Ashley these guys out I guess so why
would bolt do this I know this is pretty
cold in here yeah take this game it yeah
hammer good good yeah uh-huh hello
anyone okay what is this what is this
hey wait these suckers up offline chase
s life support oh Jesus they can all
[ __ ] up here
they're all dead Jesus okay okay yeah I
guess you know that answer and
accessible okay I'll get a different see
ya I'll see here oh great that's
disgusting
my first enemies and straight
instructions oh great
if we weren't supposed to [ __ ] and no
chase s okay security logs Jesus okay it
looks like they just sucking left
anything get here like weapons
I don't have a pit board got to fight my
way out of here
how could he says giant roaches what the
hell that get Kit Kat
what the heck is going on here oh you
like that
yeah I never block you know why get away
from me what happened here where is
everyone all that bullets [ __ ] up what
left alt oh that's that's an awkward but
in Jesus okay is this all that's left oh
how do I use I can't with used to vat
system okay okay shank yes yes yes okay
okay a gun gun oh good gut gut gut nice
coming back later for you that cry later
can I just like pugs hat
oh [ __ ] wat thum ever favorite oh okay
let's see here let's see here bobby pin
terminals gonna be somewhere there's
that terminal i just saw what to
terminal terminal gotta find the
terminal company right control access oh
sure here cry later
okay okay this has gone well oh how do I
perfect he's yet okay get good good take
this meat I love world's made honestly
it's pretty good show your sink get get
get is anyone alive yessir yessir now
this is that lock door okay
she says how you something to him oh
really my bad guys I'll pitboy yeah oh
yeah oh yeah thank yo money like that
okay good
I get the [ __ ] out of here
okay okay that's as clear my bad
ok I said am just an amateur
thank you thank you peasants
get get get yeah
this love is John
very bright very bright
[ __ ] that's pretty [ __ ] up
oh yeah how are these guys that sucks
yeah this place good were you [ __ ] up
so I guess I yes well they say well
never changes we're pretty crazy what is
that all of these aren't things oh god
they're cute flowers
mmm
Yassir codsworth what happened to well
besides aren't you Ron IAM still be of
sanctuary Hills things will be so much
more exciting with you in business [ __ ]
I can be big cooler yes yes honey and
now they stars going god damn it someone
took him someone stole my son that's
worse than I thought you're suffering
from hunger induced paranoia not eating
properly for 200 years will do that I'm
afraid
doesn't matter how long it's been
I feel fine its rotation yes yes
codsworth you're acting a little bit
weird what's wrong o king this guy is
seriously chase s stay with me pal focus
I'm afraid I don't know anything bombs
came all of you in such a hurry oh yeah
we did leave you dead oh yeah I thought
so tell I did find this hallowed happens
ah dad yeah you can't work you're
welcome hey nice to sniffing enough
feeling sorry for myself shall we
searched the neighborhood together yeah
no no I don't know codsworth fight
follow me okay cuz I keep this bursts a
maggoty ocular pat-down yeah yeah that's
disgusting ok ok wait my sensors are
picking up but in another house bother
me
wait new google is pretty dope wait it
wasn't like a ton of new call on my
fridge hold on haha I think it's like
work a lot isn't it great just great
okay where are you codsworth where are
you
see that I like payday
yeah they're pretty much gone
codsworth Sean's out there codsworth I
need to find him out cold cuts last I
checked they pummeled me with sticks a
few times before I had to run back home
okay
thanks for your help cause worth good
luck sad you'll find young sean i I'm so
sure ok where is Concord that [ __ ] [ __ ]
I got out of here the [ __ ] up oh yes oh
yes hardcore let me just make sure it's
this way
rich by take this bridge waters [ __ ]
[ __ ] up you know like some water like
even in like America so I felt like I
was put my dick in some water and it
came out purple for like three years ok
that's not normal that's not normal ok
the purple I tried sorry to rub out but
in the end they just said mark good good
oh and let's see yeah let's see here and
I'm sorry
five and ten
okay okay i gotta be cool not yeah okay
get get uh p 0 rockets rua rockets okay
create the dog no way oh oh why are you
where are you little one
come back for him later concord
ooh
out of said I get get
mmm
okay so look around around this place
other people good good
get
yeah yeah [ __ ] sucker
you